all right we continue at this hour nine
minutes now before or 10:00 p.m. Eastern
Time and that of course 7:00 p.m. on the
west coast monitoring these protests
around the country you're looking at
live pictures from Phoenix and New York
we'll bring you live reports as news
develops as I mentioned earlier today a
bombshell rod Rosenstein yep he's the
guy that appointed Muller yup he's the
guy that also signed the 4th FISA
warrant the third renewal he's also the
guy that sent the scope memorandum to
Bob Muller
what to investigate his testimony today
no collusion no evidence of collusion
his quote not sure if he even read the
whole Carter page FISA application in
the first place you're kidding me it was
big we now know is Russian
disinformation paid for by Hillary and
without which there was no FISA
application take a look you asked me
about reading the the FISA there are a
lot of FISA applications that come
through some are more significant than
others this one was unusual in that I
already knew about it
because of the Russian investigation
most of the FISA applications that are
presented to me I'm the last eyes on
them before they're filed to the court
and I know nothing about them this one
actually knew a fair amount about and
they gave it to me in advance so I could
review it not sure I read every page but
I was familiar with what was in it okay
I'll just fight all this Rosa Stein
still remember we already had debunked
starting January 21st the subs or
Christopher steel and it finally got
around to trying to verify Hillary's
misinformation Russian paid for
they found yet the sub source didn't
back up steel still didn't back up steel
that means he appointed this guy for no
reason putting the country and the
president and his administration and all
the people that work for him two and a
half years through hell which he says
well he wouldn't do now joining us with
the reaction he's leading the hearings
Senate Judiciary Committee Chairman
Lindsey Graham
I can't believe what I heard today I
cannot believe and by the way for those
people say where's Lindsey he's talking
but he's not getting it done you got it
done today and it's only the beginning
yes first step in a journey that will
end probably in October to try to
explain to the American people how the
hell did this
and how was it possible that the FBI and
the Department of Justice defrauded the
FISA Court numerous times and nobody
knew about it
what did rod Rose Stein say Rosenstein
say if I knew then what I know now what
a sign to work you know why he said that
because if you knew that the sub source
had told the FBI that the dossier was a
bunch of garbage and you signed the
warrant anyway you're a candidate to go
to jail but the most stunning thing to
me was that the scope memo outlining
what Muller could do was prepared by the
same people that defrauded the court the
ultimate the fox guarding the henhouse
the same people who lied to the court
set up the mower investigation it wasn't
Rosen Stein it was the people who lied
to the court and manipulated the
evidence set up the whole damn Muller
investigations this is a cool senator it
sounds to me like a coup attempt well
state stay tuned the bottom line is we
know that general Flynn was not working
with the Russians on January the 4th
2017 they wanted to take him out of
crossfire hurricane the FBI agents in
the Washington bureau so in August why
is his name still there
we know that Carter page was no more a
Russian agent than I am a Chinese
astronaut
we know that the dossier used against
Carter page was a bunch of garbage they
knew that in January 2017 why was his
name listed in all this 2017 senator if
if we didn't have such unrest and all
this happening these are the biggest
news they put the country through hell
on a mountain of lies great first day
we'll have you back soon